wir haben heute besuch von john hay
schon hallo karin hat vor kurzem die
höchste deutsch prüfung die man
überhaupt machen kann geschafft nämlich
die c2 prüfung am goethe institut und
für alle von euch die auch mal eine
deutschprüfung irgendwann machen werden
oder vielleicht sogar überlegen die
höchste deutsch prüfung zu machen wollen
wir ein kleines video machen und heute
schon fragen was seine erfahrungen waren
mit der prüfung schwan woher kommst du
ich bin kurz aus dem iran
und seit wann bist du in deutschland ich
bin seit 2011 in deutschland
das heißt seit neun jahren hast du
deutsch gelernt fast neun jahren genau
seitdem ich in deutschland bin gar nicht
intensiv deutsch also es gibt ja diese
verschiedenen levels und jemand der
gerade erst anfängt deutsch zu lernen
wer weiß vielleicht gar nicht was die
bedeutenden kannst du das mal klären
ja und zwar in meisten europäischen
sprachen unter anderem auch in deutsch
gibt es sechs stufen berufung erstmal a1
a2 b2 bisher ist so quasi diese mittel
niveau dann die einzige mittel nehmen
dann kommt bis 212 ist sagt man wenn man
eine ausbildung machen möchte und sehr 1
mit ist er einst mit dem z1 zertifikat
kann man ja studieren bei mancher
hochschule manche wollen c2 uns der zwar
ist das letzte was man in deutschland
machen kann und wie läuft dann so eine
prüfung ab wie lange dauert die
mit wem machst du die was musst du
machen diese prüfung hat vier teile wie
meisten anderen prüfungen und wie sie
einst oder beeindrucken air style ist
lesen zweite teil ist hören
der red teil ist schreiben und zum netz
kommt sprechen beim lesen ist es so man
hat verschiedene sachtexte die man
bearbeitet und dazu muss man
unterschiedlichen aufgaben macht beim
hören beim teil hören das ist so dass
man einfach expertengespräche hört so
oder radio interviews reportagen
drehzeit ist schreiben muss man entweder
einen aufsatz so quasi als leser 1 eine
zeitung so quasi ein zeit und die samen
einen aufsatz schreiben und am
glitzernden letzte teil ist einfach
diese sprechen teil meisten leute haben
auch angst heute sind sprechen ich finde
das ist das einfachste
im vergleich zu den anderen genau wie
bereitet man sich dann auch zur prüfung
vor
es gibt nicht nur sag ich mal einen weg
wie man sich darauf vorbereitet es gibt
viel schnee weg ist zum beispiel bei 42
prüfung ist die vorbereitung kurse von
goethe
die werden von den meisten schulen
angebot und kann man sich anmelden und
man wird die strategisch so quasi
gezielt und darauf auf die prüfung
vorbereitet das ist eine man kann hier
einfach deutschkurs zu besuchen
ich habe das nicht gemacht ich habe mich
auch angemeldet weil ich ein zwei mal da
war ich ja berufstätig war student und
familie habe ich nicht geschafft und
habe ich mich selbst zu hause
vorbereitet wie genau man muss einfach
viel lesen dass dies einfach erst mal
nur darum herumkommt man nicht es gibt
keine alternative zum lesen und vor
allem fachbücher
so anspruchsvolle texte
wissenschaftliche texte wenn man einfach
öfter dieser text ist das erstmal ein
teil ansonsten kann man ja auch im
internet diese modulprüfungen von c2
güte rufen kann man hier einfach im
internet
diese wird man das irgendwann schon
einen testmaterial übungsmaterial kann
man ja genau herunterladen online und
dann kann man ja ungefähr sehen wie
einfach eine prüfung aussieht so an du
hast die höchste deutsch prüfung
bestanden die es überhaupt gibt hast du
jetzt noch drei tipps für unsere
zuschauer ja ich mal sagen wenn sie
soweit sehen dass ich einfach sehr heiß
prüfung gemacht haben sollen sie so
schnell wie möglich sich einfach bis
zwei tropfen anmelden wir brauchen keine
angst zu haben das ist erstmal das
wichtigste ist machbar und vielleicht
wenn man sagt man sich wie man sich
besser vorbereiten kann
es ist sinnvoll wenn man einfach öfters
zeitungen liest weil einfach die themen
die in der prüfung vorkommen da sind
themen wie globalisierung
digitalisierung themen die einfach in
den zeitungen in zeitungsartikeln öfters
da sind ganze politische themen und es
ist sinnvoll wenn man sich damit dem
vorfeld beschäftigen
dann hat man einfach so quasi die
begrifflichkeiten diese ganze
fachbegriffe sind einem bekannt wenn man
das öfters gelesen hat und deswegen in
der prüfung hat man einfach überhaupt
die texte zu verstehen
die sitze so quasi zu formulieren und
auch beim sprechen da hat man ja auch
einfacher so quasi pro und contra
argumente zu bringen
danke dass du dabei warst schon danke
dir danke sie denn als ich die prüfung
bestanden habe habe ich ein foto von
meinem zertifikat beim facebook so quasi
gepostet viele freunde haben mir einfach
geschrieben wie war die prüfung und so
habe ich mir gedacht ist gut wenn ich
eine video machen würde und mich einfach
dreck an allen will
sinn würde anstatt ein jedem einzelnen
so zwei tonnen deswegen jetzt ist gute
gelegenheit dass sie einfach alle
erfahrungen die ich gemacht habe so
quasi den mitzuteilen
das ist eine sehr gute gelegenheit und
schauen dann würde es aber auch noch
persönlichen fragen beantworten ja wenn
jetzt einige unserer zuschauer fragen
haben schreibt sie hier in die
kommentare und schon ist dann steht
bereit gerne
[Musik]
[Applaus]